[Music]
the hollow Earth theory according to
this Theory our planet could be a series
of nested spheres centered around a
central core in between these shells
atmospheres could exist that are capable
of supporting life in the 17th century
Edmund hiy the scientist who discovered
hi's Comet backed this Theory many
others have added to it suggesting a
small Sun could be hanging in the center
of the earth and plants animals and
humans could be living there and not
just humans but a race of
superhumans Immortals who possess
sophisticated technology to build
hundreds of subterranean cities but if
there were aliens inside the earth what
would the conditions for life be could
the inside of our planet be a luscious
Paradise